alright so someone just sent this video
to me it's something about freight
trains
our country was built on rail
and 200 years later it's still the most
efficient way to move heavy loads
freight trains are up to four times more
energy efficient than highway trucks so
as we look to build a cleaner future how
can we better utilize rail oh no what is
this again we're bringing advanced
technology to existing rail
infrastructure to move freight between
our cities for less
opening new markets to cleaner safer
service oh my god that's not how any of
this today's powerful locomotives pull
trains that are miles long
but long trains require large-scale
terminal operations including expansive
yards to sort and cue containers
all this takes up space adds cost no no
no wait wait no way the economy of scale
it's it's at parallel systems we've
re-imagined the system by going smaller
and simpler this is made possible by our
autonomous battery-powered rail cars
independent rail cars can come to where
they're needed load easily and start
moving immediately each car is routed
directly to its destination bypassing
switch yards our technology opens up new
possibilities for the 700 billion dollar
freight trucking market while increasing
overall network capacity
this will take freight off the roads
meaning less traffic cleaner air and
quieter neighborhoods
rail has played an important role in our
country's history and by reinventing its
operations it has an exciting future
parallel systems
the future of freight israel
yes i agree but not with his brain that
[ __ ] okay be nice be nice
all right you know what two can play
this game so let's see how this amazing
innovation can be further improved get
ready parallel because i'm about to
revolutionize rail freight over here
the u.s economy was built on rail and as
we prepare to battle climate change we
at intersecting systems believe that
rail is the key to our success a cleaner
safer more efficient trade service
between cities will not only protect the
climate but also significantly boost the
economy here's how
today's autonomous battery-powered sleds
are flexible but they also have multiple
points of failure due to their design
the batteries are also sensitive to
weather posing fire risk and require
extensive charging infrastructure at
intersecting systems we re-imagine the
system by going larger and simpler this
is made possible by our centralized
power source called locomotives they can
pull trains that are miles long which
can be served by large scale terminals
that provide an excellent economy of
scale not to mention they are four times
more efficient than highway trucks the
cars are without any advanced
electronics resulting in a negligible
risk of failure thus higher efficiency
our solution is set to disrupt the 700
billion dollar freight trucking market
using locomotive hull trains instead of
trucks will lead to a multitude of
benefits rail has played an important
role in u.s history and by reinventing
its operations it has a very exciting
future intersecting systems the future
of freight is not trying to reinvent
trains and then try to bamboozle people
with cgi to try to hide the fact that
our ideas are bad
thank you for watching don't forget to
like and subscribe and do check out my
patreon if you want to be part of the
freight rail revolution
[Music]
you